I gotta fix my nose and I put two straws
on my nose but thirty years I was
looking for a strong now then putting
too strong directly in my nose what an
invention you can keep him here forever
for a week and then they pull the straws
out and they bullish drawers I had
splints my nose once you get it done oh
my god you're gonna feel so good the
right side is done I must stop that side
would blow when there's no no all I can
see is that doctor on Monday like the
dentist when they're cleaning a cavity
and she's got the goggles on and coke
rocks are hitting ya in the face and
[ __ ] aluminum foils yuba cares and God
knows what else
I snorted sheet rock whenever the [ __ ]
comes off that ceiling and carpets and
cat hair sometimes you drop a coke rock
on the floor listen that for no more
than coke rocks going down I don't give
a [ __ ] what's on the floor nails
thumbtacks lint it all goes in your nose
you deal with it in the morning and the
morning will come on something will be
there just take a nice
un-fuckin'-believable bit on a hardwood
floor would you get down on that floor
and sniff it right i [ __ ] put my
finger and whatever else was on that
finger one in my [ __ ] nose some water
and I just held it up there to melt it
and whatever happened happened oh my god
she's just crazy that's always just
crazy everything and the doctor's name
is doctor line Li and he know yeah yeah
I don't know if it's a joke the doctors
fix your nose is doctor line doctor line
that's the [ __ ] nose doctor see that's
one of those things where it just makes
you feel like we're not living in
reality this is it doc the line this
can't be real Joey it's moving it's a
[ __ ] yeah yeah we're living in a movie